in today's data driven World business
analytics skills are in high demand
across a wide range of Industries
company seek professionals who can
analyze data identify patterns and
Trends and use that information to make
informed business decisions as a result
job roles in business analysis are on
the rise with high salaries to match
according to glassor the national
average salary for a business analyst in
the United States is over
$176,000 yearly with top earns making
over1 115,000 annually are you
interested in boosting your career as a
business analyst look no further than
simply larns professional certificate
program in business analysis with simply
larns professional certificate program
in business analysis you will gain the
knowledge and skills needed to thri in
the lucrative field our comprehensive
program covers every everything from
data analysis techniques to project
management methodologies upon completing
the program you will earn a professional
certificate in business analysis that
will help you stand out to employers and
demonstrate your expertise in the field
plus our program is fully online so that
you can complete it at your own pace and
on your own schedule don't miss out this
opportunity to advance your career and
become a highly s of business analyst
enroll in simply learns professional
certificate program in business analysis
today during the course of this boot
camp we will learn about the need to
know about business analyst we will
start our journey by pondering over need
for business analyst and their
responsibilities then we'll check out
the skills required to be a business
analyst then we'll talk about business
analysis knowledge areas then we'll
learn how to do business analysis with a
skill and finally we will wrap up this
boot camp by drawing comparison between
business analyst and data analyst we
will understand the importance of
business analyst with a S and
interesting story so meet Rob he runs a
cafe in a small town far away his Cafe
is one of the oldest and most popular
eateries in town Rob's Cafe was hely
popular amongst customers and it was
doing very well until the onset of the
deadly Corona virus due to covid-19 like
other EES Rob was forced to sh down his
Cafe too this took a heavy toll on his
business and subsequently he lost his
customers none of his customers visited
his Cafe and this resulted in a huge
loss for him he knew he couldn't affort
to close his business forever as it
would take time for Corona virus to be
eradicated but he was lost this
situation was new to him and he didn't
know how to reopen his business amidst
this pandemic after a lot of
brainstorming he recollected reading
about business analysts he remembered
that business analysts are professionals
who enable a change in an organization
he felt like a business analyst could
help him sort out his current business
problems hence without wasting any any
time he set out to hire a business
analyst he hired Ted the business
analyst to help him with his ongoing
business problems Rob entrusted Ted with
reopening the business the first step
Ted took was to have a discussion with
Rob and understand the business problems
and the
objectives that is ideally the first
step a business analyst would take on
discussing with Rob Ted learned that the
business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80% of the
customer base back in addition to that
Rob also wanted Ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic Ted studied the case and he
came up with a few suggestions that he
thought was fit for Rob's
business his first suggestion was to
develop an exclusive home delivery app
for Rob's Cafe this way Ted knew that
business will improve as customers
prefer home delivery in the current
scenario next Ted suggested that Rob has
work from home meal boxes added to his
menu many professionals are working from
home currently and having work from home
meal boxes would be a good pick for such
Professionals in the middle of a busy
day Ted's third suggestion was to bring
down the selling cost by providing
discount coupons that can be utilized by
customers having a discount will enable
more customers to order from Rob's Cafe
of course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price Cuts in the current situation
finally Ted suggested the dr's staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by Ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches so after
the suggestions were accepted by Rob for
the app TED began to make sure that the
development went well by collaborating
with the IT team Ted became the
intermediary between the IT team and Rob
he provided suggestions to the team
checked the app through user interface
testing and made sure that the
requirements met well the same applied
to the other business requirements and
changes as well Ted held regular
meetings to gaze the progress and also
kept Rob in the loop and updated him
with the status of the project attending
regular catch-ups helped Rob gain an
insight into the progress and give his
feedback from time to time Ted made sure
that the entire case was well documented
by doing so he could always refer to the
documents in the future with similar
cases as well
Ted made presentations that showed Rob
the business growth after implementing
the changes and Ted always supported his
presentations with data Rob was very
impressed with Ted's business approach
such an approach not only helped Rob
reopen his business amidst the covid-19
but also helped him get 80% of his
customer base back Ted successfully
brought about a positive change in Rob's
business which was highly beneficial so
that is how Ted the business analyst
helped Rob make a business bus
sustainable this was the importance of
having a business analyst in Rob's
organization don't you think every
organization should have a business
analyst well yes depending on the
business domain and the situation the
roles and responsibilities may vary
let's start off and have a look at a day
in the life of a business analyst
through a small story so meet Angela who
is working as a business analyst in an
application development firm her firm
builds applications for clients
depending on their requirements our next
character is Rob he is a butting
entrepreneur with a vision of setting up
his own e-commerce app he plans on
selling several electronic gadgets like
phones laptops cameras Etc on his app so
what is Rob's First Step well he
approaches Angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app Angela and Rob start talking
business and Angela promises to help Rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running Rob is happy about
it and agrees to cooperate with Angela
regarding all the business requirements
from his end Angela as we know is the
business analyst she starts planning
Rob's project and without any delay she
embarks on this Project's Journey she
has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill Rob's
requirements but what are the steps she
takes is her approach going to be
effective and quick let's find out the
answers to these questions now up next
you can learn about Angela's approach
that helps her deliver Rob's project
smooth smoothly and without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these roles
better with respect to Angela's and Rob
story first and foremost Angela
understands Rob's business objectives
problems and requirements without
understanding this do you think Angela
will be able to proceed no hence a
business analyst like Angela understands
the problems related to Rob's business
and comes up with the right solution to
achieve the goals of the business she
brainstorms around what is best Ed for
an e-commerce app focusing on electronic
Gadgets in The Next Step Angela gathers
all the necessary requirements here she
understands Rob's requirements and makes
sure that they are on the same page
regarding the project and its goals both
of them together arrive at a stipulated
deadline for the project
completion she gathers relevant
information based on security of the app
the payment setup based to login cost of
the products and style to name a few
once Angela has an in-depth
understanding of Rob's project and
gathers all the necessary requirements
she starts allocating Resources by
keeping in mind the budget of the
project here she recognizes and
allocates tasks and resources to the
development team B work closely with the
development team to design the solution
for a problem Angela ensures that the
development team doesn't spend their
time understanding Rob's requirements in
this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
Angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to Rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the app's layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in The Next Step Angela
collects feedback of the Prototype
version of the app from the
users she notes down if the Prototype is
fine or if it requires more work p is
validate if the project is running fine
with the help of use acceptance testing
they verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use
expectations Bas also assess the
functional and non-functional
requirements after collecting feedback
Angela moves to one of her most crucial
duties and that is building reports data
visualization is a key skill for any ba
in order to gauge the performance of the
app and get valuable insights from it
Angela builds report reports using
various data visualization tools like
tblo powerbi and click view reports can
be General reports such as detailed
reports or it can be dashboard reports
such as visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to crop up amst this
entire process hence Angela conducts
regular meetings with the development
team and Rob to solve problems quickly
having these meetings will help Rob
understand the status of the project and
it will also help the teams proceed in
the right path throughout this project
phase Angela makes sure to maintain
transparency on completion of the
project Angela documents and presents
the project findings to Rob generally
business analysts present the project
outcomes to the stakeholders and clients
along with maintenance reports Angela
are notes on all the project learnings
and details in a concise manner this
will help her take better decisions in
the future and these documents will save
her time while implementing the next
project
now that she has completed all her
duties and responsibilities with respect
to Rob's project she is ready to deliver
the final e-commerce application to Rob
for use Rob is rest assured that the
application developed by Angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted Angela's streamlined approach
made it easier for the project to be
delivered within the stipulated time
period Rob is happy and I'm sure he will
come back to Angela's firm for projects
in the future so those responsibilities
that we saw Angela carry out are ideally
roles and responsibilities for any
business analyst out there yes some may
vary depending on the company you work
for and the project you're working on if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more business analyst is a professional
who is responsible for Bridging the Gap
between it and business
teams they use analytics to evaluate
processes determine requirements deliver
datadriven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and
stakeholders business analyst is an
individual who is a part of the business
operation and works closely with the
technology team to improve the quality
of the services being delivered they
also help in assisting in integration
and testing of new Solutions growing a
career in a field with high demand such
as business analysis could be a
challenge and competition for business
analyst positions can be intense so you
should have a clear understanding of the
roles and responsibilities of a business
analyst a ba should successfully
identify and recognize the
organization's business objective they
should understand the business problems
and think of a lucrative business
solution they need to understand and
collect the business requirements from
clients and stakeholders allocate the
right resources and improve the existing
business documentation of business
business findings is another important
key role of a business
analyst Bas interact with the
development team to design the solution
for solving a particular problem they
often need to spend a certain amount of
time in meetings in order to save the
development team from spending their
time and understanding the stakeholders
requirement they often give feedback on
the layout of a software application as
to what all features need to be added
and what functionalities should the
application contain and also implement
the newly designed features that a
business
needs while Bas identify the needs
Define the features write use cases
uncover business rules and manage issues
they should also gauge the functional
and non-functional requirements in a
business business analysts run meeting
with stakeholders and other authorities
hence discussing issues with the client
face Toof face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders ERS and
users to understand how datadriven
changes to products Services software
and Hardware can improve efficiency and
add value they verify and validate if
the project is running well with the
help of user acceptance testing and the
solutions are in line with the client's
requirements they also ensure that the
product delivered satisfies the user
requirements finally Bas write
documentations and build visualizations
to explain all the findings and draw
business ins sites they also deliver
maintenance reports they need to develop
informative coherent and usable
documents for the success of a
project business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often refer to as
soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem
so let's have a look at the top skills
to become a successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business
objective for a business analyst it is
important to know the goals and
objectives of the business it is advised
that business analyst should have a good
knowledge of the business operations in
his or her
organization a business analyst should
understand the problems related to the
business and come up with the right
solution business analysts should
resolve the problems that have been
identified and not avoid them they work
on individual actions and tasks that
will build towards the achievement of
the goals of the business objectives of
the business can be to expand customer
base in order to increase sales scale of
production so that it is in line with
the revenue growth improve revenue
streams through increasing perceived
product value or increasing marketing
budget according to the revenue business
analysts should have the Natural
Curiosity and determination to continue
learning and figuring out how things fit
together even as business analysts
become managers it is important to stay
in touch with the industry and its
changes the next important skill a
business analyst should have is
analytical and critical
thinking now there is a famous quote by
Thomas Elva Edition which says 5% of the
people think 10% of the people think
they think and the other 85% would
rather die than think business analysts
are paid to think a business analyst
would be able to analyze and interpret
the client's requirements
clearly business analysts required good
focus in order to collect and understand
the needs of the client critical
thinking involves evaluating several
options before arriving at the desired
solution in certain situations a
stakeholder may give a requirement
that's not necessarily tied up to any
business value but rather to their own
increased convenience applying critical
thinking demands not taking all the
statements of the stakeholders for
granted critical thinking allows the
business analyst to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a loow low priority a business analyst
must be creative in order to reach
stated goals where resources are limited
and the conditions are non
ideal the third important skill for a
business analyst is communication and
interpersonal
skills understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession if
you're unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message business analysts apply
communication skills at every point they
use communication and interpersonal
skills when the project is launched
while Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final
solution listening reading and writing
skills are very critical for a business
analyst this should be capable of
facilitating meetings business analysts
use verbal and written communication to
convey ideas Concepts facts and opinions
to a variety of stakeholders nonverbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact effective
listening allows the business analyst to
accurately understand information that
is being communicated
verbally fourth in our list of skills we
have negotiation and cost benefit
analysis being a success ful business
analyst requires working with and
interacting with many
people these people include clients
Business Leaders project team members
project stakeholders vendors private
sector Representatives industry leaders
and so forth business analysts negotiate
at every turn during the course of a
project at the initial stage of a
project negotiation skills are used to
determine what should be included in the
vision of the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority as the
project progresses negotiation skills
help to determine the functional design
which fulfill the requirements technical
decisions also require negotiation
skills business analysts also perform
cost benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analyst that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not business analyst
should be able to achieve a profitable
outcome for your company while finding a
solution for the client that makes them
happy this Balancing Act demands the
ability to influence a mutual solution
and maintain professional
relationship up next we have our fifth
skill that is decision
making the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact impa on
the company's business thus it is
important for every business analyst to
think from all aspects before presenting
their decision or
strategy they must be having good
problem solving skills as well business
analysts should have a act to think out
of the box and find a solution to
problems majorly a business analyst
follows five major steps while making a
decision these steps are Define the
problem find and Define the alternative
approaches evaluate the alternative
approach
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the
solution while some may argue that the
technical team is responsible for
Designing the solution the business
analyst Still Remains instrumental in
ensuring that the design confirms to the
requirements that have been approved now
that we have reached halfway through the
skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply
learn moving on we have another really
important business analyst skill that is
idea about programming
languages business analysts should have
a good Hands-On programming knowledge
for performing better and faster
analysis of data knowledge of R and
python is highly beneficial business
analysts can help solve complex Problems
by writing efficient codes both R and
python have a vast collection of
libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics some of
these libraries are numpy pandas D plier
tier ggplot and matplot lib in addition
to these it is good to understand
statistical software like SAS and SPSS
using these programming languages such
as python RN SAS you can analyze and
visualize large data sets as well as
create machine learning models for
making future business
predictions the seventh skill in our
list is creation of reports and
dashboards now business anal analyst
should be proficient in using various
business intelligence tools for creating
reports and
dashboards reports created by business
analyst can be General reports such as
detail report grouped report cross tab
report column report query report data
entry report Etc or it can be dashboard
report such as visualized Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators dashboard
reports are developed by business
analyst to solve business
decision-making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas-like operation interface
knowledge of tabue powerbi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business
requirements now the eighth skill in our
list of skills is database and
SQL business analysts often work with
data that is structured in nature hence
to store and process this data they
should have knowledge of relational
databases such as Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database mySQL database as well
as no SQL
databases also having hands-on
experience with SQL is a must for a
business analyst to access retrieve
manipulate and analyze data so they
should be able to write data definition
and data manipulation commands such as
create update delete and
insert Microsoft Excel is the ninth
skill in our
list Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with
data business analysts use Excel to
perform various calculations budget
analysis and data analysis to derive
meaningful insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create peot tables
to summarize the data business analysts
can also create different charts and
graphs using Excel to generate Dynamic
reports related to a business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecast
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analyst can list out
dates and topics in a
spreadsheet when creating a budget for a
small product they can list expense
categories in a spreadsheet update it
monthly and create a chart to show how
close the product is to budget across
each category business analyst can
calculate customer discounts based on
monthly purchase volume by product they
can even summarize customer Revenue by
product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and
presentation you could have all the
industry experience in the world but if
it's paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all a
business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting their findings and
conclusions in front of the stakeholders
and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision- making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution with that we have
covered our top skills for a business
analyst if you have any questions
related to the skills that we covered
then please put it in the chat section
our team will help you solve your
queries now let me tell you how simply
learn can help you grow your career in
business analytics and help you become a
business
analyst so let me search for simply
learn
here this is the simply learn
website and on the search bar let me
look for
business
analyst you can
see there are a few courses related to
business analyist so let me open these
two
courses so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst Masters
program now this program is windowed
education provider is
IBA now if you look on the right we have
the different courses that will be
covered as part of this master's program
so it there is introduction to business
analysis certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum there's business
analytics with Excel you'll also get
training in SQL there's Tableau training
and you'll also get to work on business
analyst capston
projects
if I scroll
down now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so
there's Microsoft Excel zaa Tableau
powerbi postest SQL then there plan box
Target process and
others here you can see the program
advisors and if I scroll further this is
the entire course content we
have these are the different courses
that you will be learning in this
course
and after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to
this so please go ahead and enroll to
this course if you want to start your
career in business analytics now let me
take you to another program we have
postgraduate program in business
analysis now this is in partnership with
podu University and endorsed education
provider is
iipa if I scroll down you can see here
the key features of this course you'll
get Purdue post-graduate program
certification alumini Association
membership master classes from Purdue
faculties enrollment in simply learns
job assist there's 170 Plus hours of
Blended learning 11 plus Hands-On
projects castom projects in three
domains if I scroll further on the right
you can see this is the puru
certification that you will receive
after finishing the course and you will
also get the certificate received by
International Institute of business
analysis that is
IBA let's scroll
down you also have the advantage for
enrolling to Simply learn job assist
program so you will get IM jobs Pro
membership for 6 months resume
assistance and career monitoring you'll
also have interview preparation and
career affairs
now here you can see the program
details so you'll learn about an
introduction to business analysis
certified business analysis professional
the agile and scrum business analytics
with Excel Tableau training business
analyst Capstone
project and you also have the
opportunity to enroll for some electives
so we have pu University business
analysis Master Class you can also
enroll to a pobi course and there's
agile and from
Foundation if I scroll down here you can
see the skills that will be covered as
part of this program so there's business
analysis there alation and collaboration
requirement analysis planning and
monitoring let me click on view more you
have strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing that's data visualization
statistical analysis using Excel SQL
database there's requirement life cycle
management and lots more more so these
are the tools that will be covered in
this course we have Microsoft Excel Zer
fog plan box that's rally powerbi pruss
SQL that's version one target process
and
others and now this is the important
part these are the industry related
projects that you will get to work on
once you enroll to this course so the
first project is canteen ordering system
for
Unilever we also have Library management
system for Stanford University there is
WhatsApp p and you can see the
description of these projects mentioned
below and you also have Hospital
management system for myoc
Clinic they are our course advisers for
this course now they are directly
related to puu
University I scroll further this is the
Learners profile and how the industry
trend has been for business
analysts so please go ahead and enroll
to this program if you really want to
start your career or you want to grow
your career as a business analyst now
here is a quick road map that depicts
what a fresher needs to possess to
become a business analyst first they
need to have a graduation degree in a
related field then knowledge of SQL and
relational database is very
important thirdly a fresher should have
good hands-on experience with with
programming languages and that's a
prerequisite and finally they need to
have good communication skills to nail
the role of a business analyst up next
we have the road map that depicts what
an experienced professional needs to
possess to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they're currently working
in next they should know how to write
SQL queries an experienced professional
should be good with programming
languages in addition to that they need
to have good communication and
negotiation
skills finally they should be good at
creating interactive reports using
business intelligence Tools in addition
to that having a certification offered
by International Institute of business
analysis such as certified business
analysis professional would be highly
beneficial let's now learn the business
analysis knowledge
areas first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring now this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize and coordinate business
analysis efforts it involves planning
business analysis approach stakeholder
engagement business analysis governance
as well as Information Management then
we have elicitation and
collaboration now this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to prepare and
conduct elicitation activities and
confirm the results it also includes
communicating business analysis
information and stakeholder
engagement the third knowledge area we
have is requirements life cycle
management so this knowledge area
describes the task that we perform in
order to manage and maintain
requirements throughout their life cycle
it covers the creation changes
prioritization traceability and
governance processes fourth in our list
we have strategy
analysis now this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to identify the
business need address that need and
align the change strategy within the
Enterprise you need to analyze the
current state Define the future State
assess risk and Define change
strategy then we have requirements
analysis and design definition this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize requirements specify and
model requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures as assess solution limitations
and recommends actions to increase
solution value now let's discuss two of
the most widely used methodologies in
any business analysis process these
methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects the first methodology we are
going to talk about is the agile
methodology agile is an incremental and
iterative approach to project management
and software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles teams can
manage a project by breaking it up into
several stages and involving constant
collaboration with stakeholders along
with continuous Improvement and
iteration at every
stage so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes planning
the project in terms of business goals
budget time duration for completing the
project and resource needed then we have
designing the solution for the problem
at hand the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application Etc it's done by
the development team next we have
testing the product in the next step of
the life cycle deploying the developed
product to check if it's working fine
and finally we have reviewing the
product and getting feedback from
customers clients stakeholders Etc now
in agile methodology the entire work is
broken down into several Sprints after
each Sprint we get a shippable product
and that product is reviewed by the
client or the stakeholder folder the
suggestions are Incorporated in the next
Sprint here you can see we have Sprint 1
Sprint 2 and Sprint 3 and all of them
have the six steps that we discussed in
the agile methodology process now let's
discuss the scrum
methodology scrum is a subset of the
agile framework it is one of the most
widely used lightweight process
Frameworks for Agile development you can
easily collaborate develop and deliver
complex products of of the highest
possible value scrum empowers the
development team and supports working in
small teams like 8 to 10 members scrum
significantly increases productivity and
reduces time this process enables
organizations to adjust smoothly to
rapidly changing requirements and
produce a product that meets evolving
business goals okay so the concepts and
practices in scrum can be divided into
three categories first we have three
roles a product owner owns the product
backlog and writes user stories and
acceptance criteria they are responsible
for prioritizing the product backlog and
deciding the release date and the
content a product owner is the one who
is responsible for the return on
investment or Roi of the product a scrum
Master is a servant who encourages and
demands self-organization from the
development team they enable close
cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
Disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
increments the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shipable product each Sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an uded
list of the features and requirements
needed to complete the project the list
can include bugs or defects that need to
be resolved features that must be added
and other technical or Project work your
team has to complete before the project
is over the Sprint backlog includes only
what needs to be completed during the
current Sprint it often has greater
detail and more complete user stories
than the rest of the product backlog
once created no one can add to the
Sprint backlog except the development
team the product increment is the
version of the product that will be
delivered at the end of each Sprint
while the Sprint backlog outlines what
must be completed within a Sprint the
product increment details the outcome of
all that work the increment is a
prototype or working version of the
final product expected by the customer
the final category we have is Sprint
ceremonies there are four ceremonies in
total in Sprint planning the team meets
and decides what they need to complete
in the coming Sprint Sprint review is a
type of meeting in which the team
demonstrates what they shed in the
Sprint in the Sprint retrospective the
team reviews their work identifying what
they did well and what didn't go as
planned so that they can make the next
Sprint better daily scrum is a standup
meeting or a very short like 15 to 20
minutes meeting for the team to make
sure that they are all on the same page
now let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst according
to pay scale the average annual salary
of a business analyst in the United
States is $ 68,9
73 while in India a business analyst can
earn nearly 6 lakh rupees perom now
talking about the companies hiring for
business analyst we have the Indian
e-commerce payment system and financial
technology company PTM American MNC
cognizant and British Dutch
multinational oil and gas company shell
we also have Cisco the search engine
giant Google and Dell finally in our
list of companies we have onon young
Global limited American multinational
computer technology corporation Oracle
and British multinational Investment
Bank and financial services company baky
with that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts we have the widely
used spreadsheet application Microsoft
Excel web-based Canen style list making
application Trello relational database
Management systems such as MySQL
Microsoft SQL server and postgress SQL
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product Zera and tblo
software for data
visualization okay so let's look at our
demo on business analyst training often
times business analysts work on
structured data using Excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create P tables and P charts to
summarize and analyze data find Trends
and insights to make critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the United States and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
Etc now let me show you the data set
first okay so here is my data set you
can see there are nearly
9,994 rows and we
have 17 columns you can see this is a
sales data set and the First Column is
of order date then we have the shipment
date we have the shipment mode next we
have the customer name that is the
customer who purchased the product we
have the segment the country name this
is only United States then we have the
different cities from the US we have the
state names
and if I go to the right you can see the
categories of product we also have the
subcategories next we have the product
name then we have our sales value now
you can assume this to be in
dollars then we have the quantity that
was sold for each product then we have
the discount column and finally we have
the profit
column so let's analyze this data set
using different charts and graphs for
first let's create a pivote table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the ears in
different regions of the United States
so for that I'll click on any cell
inside this data set go to the insert
Tab and here I have the option to create
a pivote table I'll click on this create
pivot table option and you can see it
has selected my entire data and here
I'll choose new worksheet that is the
place where I want to place this p table
and let's click on
okay so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet two and let's drag
our columns onto the different sections
in this pivot table Fields so since I
want to know the region and the year so
let's drag the order date
first
and let's delete the quarter column so
I'll click on remove
field I don't want this field so I have
my ears first and then let's
drag region
column under
columns and we want to know the sales
for all the years in different regions
so I'll drag sales onto
values you can see here we we have our
pivote table ready if you want you can
go ahead and rename these row labels and
column
labels now with this table ready let's
create a line chart this will help you
analyze your data better so what you can
do is go to the insert Tab and here
under recommended charts you can go for
line chart you can see the line chart
preview here and click on okay
there you go how easily Excel has
created a pivote chart for US based on
this pivote
table now if you notice the lines in
this graph you can see the different
regions and here is the legend now if
you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region so the
sales had declined from
2014 to
2015 and then it gradually started
increasing from 2015 to 2017
onwards and if you see the orange line
or the red line it is for the east
region the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly if you see the central region
the sales generated was steady from 2014
till
2015 then it increased in 2016 and after
2016 it became
constant similarly you can analyze the
South Region as
well now let's say you want to know the
sales by each category of product and
the different segments so you can do
that as well let's go to our sheet one
where we have our data set let me click
on any cell I'll go to insert and I'll
choose pivote table here let it be new
worksheet I'll click on okay all right
so since we want to know the sales value
again so let's drag sales onto values
field and now now I'll
choose
category under rows
so let's select category under rows and
then we want to know for each segment
also so what I can do is I'll choose
segment under columns you can see I have
my P table ready so here you have the
furniture office supplies and Technology
as the categories of products and on the
top you can see consumer corporate home
office as the different
segments now let's create
a visual out of this pivote table so
I'll go to recommended charts and let's
say this time I want
to create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart let's click on okay
if I close
this and I bring it to here you can see
this is a nice bar chart and Below you
can see the sales values and on the
y-axis you can see the different
categories of products and in the legend
we have the segments now if you want you
can edit this chart as well so let's
delete or hide all field buttons on the
chart all right similarly let's do this
for our line chart as well let's hide
these
field buttons
okay all right
now let's suppose you want to know which
segment meet the highest and the lowest
profits so for that you can create a p
table as well so I'll click on any cell
go to the insert Tab and choose pivote
table I'll click on okay all right now
say we want to know the profit by each
segment so I'll first choose profit onto
values
and let's drag the segment
column onto rows so we have our pivot
table
ready now here if you want to know which
segment meet the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any sell under sum of
profit right click and here you have the
short option so let's do s smallest to
largest which is in ascending order okay
so here you can see consumer segment
meet the highest amount of profit while
the home office segment meet the lowest
amount of profit now based on this pivot
table you can create a pie chart let's
do that I'll go to insert and here under
recommended charts I'll select pi and
let's click on okay there you go we have
a nice pie chart ready now the gray
color pie represents your consumer
segment which meet the highest amount of
profit you can also validate it from the
P table while the blue segment which is
actually home office made the lowest
amount of profit now let's remove this
field from here I'll right click and
select hide all field buttons on the
chart now one thing you can do is you
can edit the chart Title Here by default
it has shown total we can rename it to
let's say profit
by segment and hit
enter okay now you can adjust the size
of this and the color of the text if you
want you can do it from here similarly
let's add a title to our bar graph as
well so here if you
see there's an option to choose chart
title and I'll say say sales
by
segment and
category okay similarly let's add a
title to our first line chart that we
created I'll click on the chart title
and here I'll write sales by year and
region
okay now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know the total units that were
sold for each subcategory of products
and the shipment mode so here we have
the shipment mode and you want to know
the total units that were sold which is
basically this column the quantity
column for each subcategories of product
you can see we have different
subcategories like bookcases the chairs
labels The Stables Furnishings art
phones binders Etc so let's create a
pivote table for this I'll go to the
insert tab click on pivote table and
click on okay all right now since we
want to know the total units that were
sold let's drag the quantity column
under
values and I'll
choose the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
subcategory under rows so I have my P
table ready now based on this P table
let's create a line chart I'll go to the
insert tab click on recommended charts
and let's go to line
chart all right you can see the preview
here and the Legends which show the
shipment mode Let's click on
okay I'll close this now first let's
remove these fields I I'll right click
and I'll hide all field buttons now if
you see this one you can add some styles
to your chart let's modify our chart a
bit let's say I'll
select yeah this one you can see it has
given dots for each end points which
means this is my first subcategory as
you can see the second subcategory of
the Third subcategory which is artart
then we have binders so it's really easy
to read and understand the chart
well okay now let's add a chart
title I'll
write
quantity
sold by
subcategory and ship
mode
now you can reduce the size of the chart
title text let's keep
it 10
okay now you also have the feature to
create different kinds of maps in
Excel so
suppose you want to see the states that
meet the highest and the lowest sales in
the United States so you can create a
field map for that so first of all let's
go to our data sheet I'll click on any
cell go to insert and create a pivote
table I click on okay all right so since
we want
the state and the country so let me
first drag country field under rows and
then I'll choose the State field under
rows now let's drag sales under
values okay so we have our
pivot table ready now if I sort this
data you can easily
know that California state made the
highest amount of sales now if I scroll
down below you can
see North Dakota made the lowest amount
of
seals now let's do one thing let's
remove the grand total so you can go to
the design Tab and under Grand totals
you can select the first option you can
see the grand total has
gone and in order to create a map we
need to adjust this P table so I'll
click on United
States I'll right click and I'll go to
field
settings here under layout and print
I'll click on show item labels in
tabular format and I'll also click on
repeat item labels you can
see it will populate United States for
all the rows if I click on okay you can
see the United States have been
populated for all the
states now let
me select this
table or before that let's remove
the subtotal from here I'll close this
go to the design tab under
subtotals I'll choose to not show
subtotals okay now let's
select the
table and I'll actually paste it
somewhere
here now with this data I can go to the
insert Tab and choose Maps let's select
field map there you
go you see we have a nice field map of
the United States and here you can see
the color
scale so it goes from light G all all
the way up to dark blue so the states
that are in dark blue let's say
California made the highest amount of
sales you can also validate it from the
pivote table similarly the lighter the
color the amount of sales were less for
that state now let's give a chart title
here I'll give a chart title
as sales by States
and let's remove this
Legend now you can format this map so
here you can change colors and let's see
if I choose this one you can see the
color has
changed and you can see the California
state is shaded in dark which means it
made the highest amount of sales you can
also add data labels you can see it will
show the sales values for each of the
states and if you want you can keep the
legend as well I'll just remove these
two all right now similarly you can also
create a field map to see the profits by
each state so you can analyze which
states meet the highest amount of profit
and the state that meet the lowest
amount of profit so let's do that I'll
go to my data
sheet I'll click on insert and select
pivote table let's click on
okay now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows and then I'll choose
State under
rows next let's Drag The Profit column
under
values so I have
my pivote table
ready let's go to the design Tab and
remove the subtles
I'll select do not show sub toal if I
scroll
down okay I have my grand total now so
let's go to the design tab under Grand
toles we'll remove it okay now let's
just populate the United States which is
the country name for all the
rows I'll right click on United States
go to field settings click on layout and
print I'll choose select item labels in
tabular form and select repeat item
labels let's click on okay so I have my
country name populated
throughout let's select the pivote
table I'll paste it somewhere
here and now let's go to the insert tab
I'll choose map let's select field
map there you go now we have the profits
for each of the
states let's first delete
this and edit our chart
title which
is profit
by
States okay let's close
this let's
say we'll use this one
now okay let's edit the color of the
chart
title I'll make it as
white and let's
say
We'll choose the
color
as say this one okay now let me go ahead
and remove the legend here and just
delete it all right so we have our field
map ready which shows profit by each
state now that we are done with our
analysis and creating our
different pivot tables and pivote charts
let's build the final
dashboard so let's create a new sheet
here okay the first thing I need to do
is I'll go to the view Tab and I'll
remove the grid lines all right now
let's go to the insert Tab and here we
have text let me choose text
box let's create a text box here
okay now you can reduce the size
actually let's reduce
it
okay and you can move it to the
top all right let's pull this a little
down and this to little
right let's fill the text box color with
blue color and let's give the text as
sales
dashboard and
we'll give a white color to the text and
I'll select my font you can select any
font you want so I'll go
with let's
say Brittanic bold okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to
30 and we'll Center align it all right
now the next step is
to bring all our pivote charts to this
dashboard sheet so I'll first copy
my pivote
chart and I'll paste it in sheet 8 let's
paste it
here and we can reduce the
size okay now similarly let's do it for
the other charts as well I'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere
here okay now let me just reduce the
size and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11 okay and let's drag this a bit
all right now
let's copy the pie
chart and let me paste it here let's
reduce the size of this pie
chart
okay see we have our pie chart here
now let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by different subcategories
of product I'll copy it and let me paste
it somewhere here I'll close
this we need to reduce the size so that
we can fit in our other charts as
well okay let me reduce a bit
more all right now we are left with the
two maps that we created let's copy this
and let's paste it
here I'll go to the
right let's reduce the
size similarly we'll do it
for sales
by profit map as
well let's copy this and paste it onto
our
dashboard let's reduce the size
first and let's increase
it towards the
bottom so we have our dashboard ready
you can see the different P charts that
we
created now let's add slicers and
timelines to this Dash so that we can
filter our tables and the charts so I'll
click on this first chart which is our
line chart I'll go to the insert tab
here you can see under filters we have
slicers and timeline first let me click
on Tim line and here I'll choose my
order date column let me click on okay
all right let's drag this a bit here
onto the right and I'll show you how you
can use this
let's first choose years instead of
months and let me reduce the size a bit
okay now another thing to do here is let
me right click and I'll go to report
connections here I'll select all my
pivote tables instead of just one so
that any manipulation you do in the
order year it will reflect for all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard I click on
okay now that we have seen how to add a
timeline I'll reduce this a bit let's
now add a few
slicers let's click on any of the charts
I'll go to insert click on
slicer now let's add a region slicer
I'll click on
okay and let's take it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slicers are nothing but filters
which have advanced filtering
options
and we can add one more filter or a
slicer let's
say we want to do this time
on the segment so I'll go to
slicer I'll choose segment here and
click on okay so you can see I have my
segment slicer here let me just reduce
the
size and let's drag it here at the
bottom all
right okay now if you want to know the
sales and profit for a particular year
so you can choose that particular year
here on the timeline suppose I want to
know the sales only for 2014 and 20 5 so
the way to do is you can select one of
the years so I'll click on
2014 and now I'll drag this to select
2015 as
well if I go to
left the figures that you see only
reflect the sales and the profit for
2014 and 15
similarly if you Mark here or let me
just bring it to the middle
suppose say I want
to have 2016 year included as well I can
just drag it to the right you can see
the charts will
change I'll just remove the filter and
place it here similarly if you want to
see the sales and profit
for a particular region you can do that
too for example let me just bring this
region slicer
here and let's say you want to know the
sales and profit only for the east
region you see here it shows only for
the east region and suppose you want to
see for east and west region also you
can see it changes
here okay me just cancel
this now you might be wondering when we
selected the different regions only the
pie chart changed but but the rest of
the charts were the same now the reason
was we did not apply this slicer to all
the pivote tables so let me right click
and go to report connections here I'll
choose the remaining pivote tables as
well I click on okay all right now let
me just bring this to the middle and
let's say we want to know the sales and
the profits and the quantity sold for
let's say south region
if I select this you can see it shows
only for the South Region let's see you
also want to know for the central region
now we have selected both Central and
South you can see the variations in the
graph and we cancel this similarly we
have our another slicer which is the
segment I'll populate the slicer for all
the other pivot
tables let me choose all of them and
click on okay okay I'll bring this to
the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say I want
to know the sales the unit souls and the
profit for home office segment so I'll
only select home office you can see the
variations here now the slices actually
don't work for the maps so you can't see
any change here now suppose you want to
know for the corporate segment you can
select corporate or if you want to
select for multiple segments you can do
that as well the just cancel
this and let me place it
here all right now we are done with our
demo so if you want to get a copy of the
data set and the demo file that we are
using here in this video you can put
your email IDs in the comment section
our team will send you the files over
email we'll compare the two most popular
job roles in the field of Information
Technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst business analyst is
a professional who Bridges the gap
between the it and the business teams in
an organization they use data analytics
and modern Technologies to assess
processes and deliver data driven
solutions they understand and solve a
business problem and validate business
requirements a business analyst
generates reports for executives and
stakeholders they part of the business
operation and work closely with the
technology team to improve the quality
of the services being delivered they
also assist in the integration and
testing of new Solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst with the rapid
increase in data generation today the
term data analyst has found its
prominence a data analyst collects
processes and performs analysis of large
data sets every business generates data
in several formats this data can be in
the form of customer information and
feedback log files transaction data
marketing research and so on it is the
duty of a data analyst to transform the
these business data into valuable
insights some of the problems that can
be addressed are how to improve a
business how to provide good customer
experience what would be the ideal price
for a new product how to reduce
Transportation costs and so on data
analyst deal with data handling data
modeling and Reporting with this brief
understanding of the job description for
a business analyst and a data analyst
let's now shift our Focus towards the
various responsibilities of a business
analyst a business analyst identifies
the business goals understands the
problems faced by an organization and
comes up with a cost-effective solution
to tackle the issues they thoroughly
understand the requirements from the
clients and assign the right resources
Bas communicate and work closely with
the development team to design the
solution for a problem they ensure that
the development team doesn't spend their
time understanding the stakeholders
requirements and often give iterative
feedback on the solution being developed
they check and validate if the project
is running fine with the help of user
acceptance testing they also verify if
the solution being worked on is in line
with the requirements and ensure that
the final product satisfies the user
expectations Bas assess the functional
and non-functional requirements a
business analyst documents the project
findings and results they present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions now
let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst first
and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process data analysts collect
data from various heterogeneous sources
they assess the available resources
comprehend the business problem and
gather the right data for analysis they
work closely with different team members
like programmers business analysts and
data scientists data filtering and data
wrangling are wider jobs of a data
analyst the data collected is often
noisy and it contains missing values
hence it is crucial to clean the
collected data and remove invalid values
to make it ready for analysis they use a
variety of analytical statistical and
business intelligence tools to spot
Trends and patterns in complex data sets
discover hidden insights and prepare
summary reports for the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data
manipulation now it's time for us us to
understand the difference between a
business analyst and a data analyst
based on the skill set they
possess first let's look at the skills
that can help you become a ba a business
analyst should have a graduation degree
in any relevant field such as business
accounting Information Systems human
resources or engineering you can apply
for entry-level business analyst
positions or with professional
experience Excel is a powerful analytics
and reporting tool for working with data
Bas use Excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions Bas use SQL
to retrieve manipulate and analyze data
stored in relational databases critical
thinking skills are important to
understand customers business needs it
allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a lower priority Bas should find
different ways to address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
Bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project knowledge of tblo powerbi and
click view is required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements business analyst
should have a good Hands-On programming
experience to solve complex tasks and
perform faster analysis of data hence
knowledge of programming languages such
as R and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skill skills they should
also be confident about their findings
and conclusions and communicate it in
front of the stakeholders and clients
let's Now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess you must
have a bachelor's degree in any relevant
field or be a graduate in statistics
economics or science you're eligible to
become a data analyst being a fresher or
as an experienced professional you
should have domain knowledge in the
field you are working in once again
knowledge of excel is another basic
requirement for a data analyst data
analysts often work with structured data
so they should be proficient in writing
SQL queries using data manipulation and
data definition commands they should
know how to create stored procedures
another crucial skill for a data analyst
is to have hands-on experience with
programming languages such as python R
SAS and JavaScript you can analyze and
visualize large data sets and create
predictive models for making business
decisions data analysts create data
visualizations using librar such as M
plot lib cbon ggplot and plotly this
helps them to perform exploratory data
analysis knowledge of Tableau and
powerbi is required to create different
business reports with the help of graphs
and charts data analyst should have
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
to build sophisticated models and make
future predictions so they should know
about linear regression logistic
regression support Vector machines k
mean clustering and other supervised and
unsupervised learning algorithm
finally data analyst should also possess
good communication and presentation
skills now let's discuss the salary
structure for both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the United States earns an
average salary of
$69,000 while in India you can earn
nearly 6 lakh rupees per anim now
talking about the salary of a data
analyst according to payscale in the US
a data analyst earns an average salary
of
$6,717 you can earn around
424,000 rupees perim let's now move on
and look at the different companies
hiring for business analyst roles here
we have Oracle the search engine giant
Google the American MNC cognizant and
e-commerce company Amazon in addition to
that we have Ernest and Young technology
giant IBM Dell and Cisco hiring business
analysts talking about the company's
hiring for data analyist we have Twitter
Google the social media leader Facebook
and Amazon we also have the American Oil
Company shell the electric vehicle
company Tesla apple and the American
Credit Reporting Agency
Equifax now choosing the right field
that is to become a business analyst or
a data analyst could be a challenging
task the key points that you have to
keep in mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best and finally consider your
long-term goals and see the job roles
that will help you grow in your career
in the long run now let me tell you how
simply learn can help you grow your
career as a business analyst and a data
analyst simply learn offers a
post-graduate program in business
analysis that is in collaboration with
puru University the endorsed education
provider is IBA some of the skills that
will be covered in this course are
strategy analysis wire framing solution
evaluation dashboarding data
visualization agile scrum methodology
scrum artifacts statistical analysis
using Excel and SQL
database some of the tools covered in
this course are Microsoft Excel Tablo
powerbi J postr SQL planbox and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive per two postgraduate program
certification master classes from puru
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get IM jobs
Pro membership for 6 months and obtain
35 IBA PD cdus and 25 PMI pdus you will
get 170 Plus hours of Blended learning
along with Capstone projects in three
domains to become a data analyst you can
enroll in the postgraduate program in
data analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
Peru University and IBM
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using Excel data analysis in
Python and are data visualization using
tblo and powerbi linear and logistic
regression modules clustering using K
means supervised learning and others the
tools that you will learn are numai
pandas scipi pyit learn Excel and
others some of the key features of this
course are you will get Pur your
post-graduate program certification in
industry recognized IBM certificates
enrollment and simply learns job assist
and master classes from puru faculty you
have 180 Plus hours of Blended learning
14 plus Hands-On projects on integrated
labs and Capstone projects in three
domains so please go ahead and enroll
for these programs if you want to grow
your career as a business analyst or a
data analyst and this was all for this
boot camp hope you guys found this
informative and helpful if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have have any questions then you can
drop them in the comment section below
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from Simply
learn hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here